[APPLAUSE]
SUE BLACK: Hi, everyone.
Thanks very much for
inviting me along here today.
I think you now know almost
everything about me, apart
from what I'm going
to tell you now.
That was a great
talk from Dermot.
And it was really lovely
for me, because I've
known Dermot for some time,
because of our involvement
with Bletchley Park, to
actually hear your talk, Dermot.
That was really cool.
So I suppose I first got
involved with Bletchley Park,
I first went up there in 2003.
So at the time, I was
I think a PhD student,
and I'd set up a network
for women in tech, BCSWomen.
And I went up there
for a meeting.
I didn't really know very
much about Bletchley Park.
I think all I knew then really--
well in fact, what I thought
I knew wasn't correct-- was
that there were probably
about 50 old guys
that worked there.
And I just kind of
imagined them sitting
around code breaking,
kind of smoking pipes,
wearing tweed jackets, and
maybe doing the Times crossword
on the side.
And that's kind
of how I thought--
that's what I thought was
happening at Bletchley Park
the first time I went there.
So I went there for a meeting.
And after the meeting, I went
for a walk around the site
and ended up bumping
into these guys who
were building this amazing kind
of like feat of engineering
in the corner of
one of the huts.
And I went over and
chatted to them,
and found out that actually that
was Turing's Bombe machine they
were rebuilding.
They were about halfway
through it at the time.
I started chatting to the guys
about what they were doing,
and then they asked
me why I was there.
So I said I'm here
representing this group, Women
in Technology.
And John Harper, the guy that
was leading the team said, oh,
did you know that more than
half the people that worked here
were women?
So I said no, I didn't
know any women worked here.
How many people worked here?
So he said more than 10,000.
So I was like completely
blown away by that, A,
because 10,000 people, and I
thought it was 50 old guys.
And B, because more than half
of those people were women.
So I went away that
time really wanting
to raise awareness of the women
that worked at Bletchley Park.
And eventually,
after some time, I
managed to raise some funding
to run an oral history project.
So we interviewed some of
the women that worked there,
because I really
wanted to capture
their memories
because, of course,
they weren't spring chickens.
They were getting on
a bit, unfortunately.
And I was really
worried that everyone
that knew what happened
there would die before we
got a chance to interview them.
I forgot to put
my slides forward.
So this is the BCSWomen
Group here in 2002.
So it was about
a year after this
that I went up to Bletchley
Park representing them.
And so here are
some of the women
that worked at Bletchley Park.
And two of the women
that we interviewed,
Ruth Bourne and Jean
Valentine, are standing here
with the Bombe machine.
So they were Bombe operators.
So we ran this oral
history projec.
And at the launch of
that, at the BCS--
the British Computer
Society in London--
I gave a talk
saying, you know, why
I thought we needed to record
the women's memories, the women
that worked there.
And then Simon Greenish, who was
then the CEO of Bletchley Park,
gave a talk.
And he said that he was
really worried that Bletchley
Park might have to close.
So at the time, he was
worried that-- everyone
was talking about a
swine flu epidemic,
and he was really
worried that the visitor
numbers might drop if there
was a swine flu epidemic.
And the main money that
Bletchley Park had then, too,
came from gate receipts,
so from people visiting.
He was really worried that if
the numbers of people visiting
dropped, the income coming
into Bletchley Park would drop
and so they'd have to close.
So he told us about
that, and he said
that he thought that
Bletchley Park was--
his words were "teetering
on a financial knife edge."
So I kind of-- after that day, I
was kind of worried about that.
I thought that was wrong.
But then I got invited up to
a reception at Bletchley Park
a couple of months later
and did a proper tour,
which I had not done before,
with one of the veterans.
I got to hear much more about
what happened there, and was
told that the work
done at Bletchley Park
was said to have shortened
the war by two years,
and that 11 million
people a year
were dying during World War II.
And I just had
this moment where I
was standing looking at this hut
with a blue tarpaulin listening
to a veteran who
worked there telling us
about the major code breaking
achievements at Bletchley Park.
And I just stood there
thinking, and this place
might have to close?
That's terrible.
So I went away and basically
started a campaign to save it.
By that time-- so this
is a few years later--
I was then head of department at
the University of Westminster,
head of a computer
science department.
So I just thought to
myself, what can I do?
You know, Bletchley
Park can't close.
Just the-- all the
stuff that happened
there is just really
incredible, and not
enough people know about it.
And so I was kind of
trying to work out
what I could do about it.
Then I saw that
there was someone
who had set up a petition on
the 10 Downing Street website
saying the government needs
to save Bletchley Park.
So I found the link to that.
I sent it round to all the
other heads and professors
of computer science
in the country,
because we were all
on an email list,
asking them to
sign the petition.
I sent a photo of the hut
with the blue tarpaulin
and said that the work that
was done there shortened
the war by two years, and
11 million people a year
were said to have been
dying, and asked everyone--
or asked all the heads and
professors across the UK--
to sign the petition.
And then I looked at the
petition-- so in those days,
you could see who'd
signed the petition.
I looked at the petition
a few hours later,
and was amazed to find
that the people that
had written the
textbooks for me when
I was a student of
computing at university, I
recognized lots of
the names of really
famous professors of
computing from around the UK.
So I got very excited
then because I just
thought, OK, it's not
just me that thinks this.
All these people that
I think, oh my god, I'm
not worthy to even contact
them, had signed it as well.
So that kind of gave me the
confidence to move forward.
So that was very cool.
I decided to set up a
blog and try and raise
awareness of what
happened at Bletchley Park
and how important it was.
So here's my blog here.
Looks very old school now.
It's quite funny-looking a bit.
So that was about 2008.
And then I was just
trying to work out well,
what else can we do?
So all these people who
are professors of computing
care about this as much as I do.
What can I do about that?
So basically, I emailed
all the journalists
that I knew and said, I
think this is a story.
We need to save Bletchley Park.
And luckily, one of
those journalists
was Rory Cellan-Jones
from the BBC.
And so the next week after that,
he took me up to Bletchley Park
and filmed me there
and got that out
on BBC News and Today Program.
And that went worldwide, which
was a bit of a shock for me,
because I wasn't really used
to being in the media when
suddenly-- you know, like
one week I'm just, like,
a normal head of
department at university.
And the next week, I have
friends in Australia saying,
I just saw you on
TV, like BBC America.
So it was a bit of a
shock, but it was good.
And I got to do my first
live TV, which is very scary.
And I actually-- I remember
sitting there thinking,
if only I could just have
a heart attack and die.
I would prefer that to going
on live TV, like News at One
or whatever it was.
But unfortunately, I didn't die.
Or fortunately.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, it was a great
learning experience for me.
So that was great.
The message got out there.
Lots of people got
in touch by email.
But then like a week later, two
weeks later, three weeks later,
what was I going to do?
I couldn't go back
to the news, right?
I couldn't go back and
say it's a new story,
because it's not a new story.
So news needs to be new.
So I was casting
around for some time
trying to work out what to do.
And then a few months
later, I started
using Twitter in earnest really.
I'd signed up before and
thought it was rubbish,
and then just kind of left it.
And then I ended
up at a conference
sitting next to people
that loved Twitter.
And so it was like
the end of 2008.
And I suddenly realized
actually Twitter
could be a way of really getting
out there, finding people that
care about Bletchley
Park, and kind of creating
a community of people that cared
about Bletchley Park and kind
of work together
to try and raise
the profile of Bletchley Park.
So through Twitter, I
didn't really tweet much
about Bletchley Park.
But already, just because
I had the link to my blog
in my Twitter bio,
then lots of people
started getting in touch
with me saying they wanted
to help to save Bletchley Park.
So that was amazing.
And so here are the photos that
you can see here on screen.
So there's Captain
Jerry Roberts,
who's one of the
code breakers who led
the Testery at Bletchley Park.
He's an amazing guy.
So he'd got in touch
with me in the summer
when I'd first been on TV.
He's there giving a talk at UCL.
And his talk's online,
so I recommend--
if you google Captain
Jerry Roberts UCL,
you should get his-- he's got
a one-hour lecture about what
he did there, which
is really interesting.
And these other guys,
too, in the other photos.
So people that got in
touch me through Twitter,
who were like social
media gurus-- you know,
knew a lot more about
social media and Twitter
than I did in 2008.
And so we all went along to
one of Captain Jerry Roberts's
talks, and then we all
went up to Bletchley Park
I think the next day.
And it was really great to
see people who really knew
what to do with social media
at Bletchley Park, you know,
just so excited about
everything that was there,
trying to kind of
cover everything
and kind of get the
message out there.
And so within a few
days really, I kind of
realized that
actually Twitter was
an amazing tool, an amazing
way to really sort of amplify
your voice.
And running a campaign
through Twitter really
made a massive
impact quite quickly.
So another thing that
happened through Twitter
was that-- so, you
know, I'd started
trying to build a
community, get people
excited about Bletchley Park.
And I was trying
to think of people
who were kind of, like,
key, influential people
who might be interested
in Bletchley Park.
And I saw this photo.
Stephen Fry posted this photo
in I think February 2009.
And-- oh, the date's on there.
Yeah, February 2009.
So he posted this photo
saying basically they're
stuck in a lift in
Centre Point in London
and they couldn't get out.
And it's like he was
tweeting, you know,
like we've rang
the emergency bell,
we've tried phoning the number.
No one's come.
So we just tried
tweeting, as well.
So I saw that photo of Stephen
Fry, and I thought Stephen Fry,
he must be interested
in Bletchley Park.
So I googled Stephen
Fry Bletchley Park,
and sure enough he was.
And there were various
quotes from him saying stuff
like if Bletchley
Park were to close,
it'd be like Nelson's
Column falling down.
And all sorts of
stuff like that.
So I knew he was on board.
So luckily, he was
following me on Twitter.
So I sent him several
direct messages
saying if you got
involved in the campaign,
I'm sure you'd make a
really big difference.
You know, please could
you tweet about it.
And the next morning,
I got this tweet.
So Stephen Fry
tweeted out a link
to my blog asking people
to sign the petition.
And instead of--
I was getting then
I think about 50 hits
a day on my blog,
which I thought was great.
But then with one tweet from
Stephen Fry, I got 8,000.
So that kind of shows
you the difference.
And I think then he had
like 200,000 followers,
whereas now he's
got several million.
So it just kind of shows you,
if you find the right people,
you can just have a massive
impact really quickly.
So over-- I guess the
campaign kind of ran really
over about three years.
So I've just told you roughly
about the stuff that happened
in the first six months.
But what we did-- because
lots and lots of people
got involved, and
you know, I was kind
of like cheerleadering the way.
But lots of people were
just doing their own thing.
So we had people
organizing comedy nights
as a benefit for Bletchley
Park, people walking up
to Everest base camp.
Just really, really cool stuff.
And just loads of
people just went off
and did their own
thing, which I think
was really cool, to raise
money for Bletchley Park
and awareness of Bletchley Park.
And one great thing that
we realized early on
was that, because we
had so many people who
were quite active
on social media
and understood tech,
basically lots of geeks,
it was quite easy to get
them to talk to other people.
You know, practically
everyone I spoke
to I said, what can you
do for Bletchley Park,
and go and tell
all your friends.
And it really did work.
You know, the message
really spread.
And so I might have
kind of started it off,
but it just kind of
gradually just got
bigger and bigger and
bigger, and more and more
people involved,
which was amazing.
So what happened with various
things like the Building
with Pride award, which
I think this is about?
Yeah, building prize.
The Building with
Pride award was--
so there'd be some organization
which would have a competition,
and this one was
Building with Pride.
And basically, you need lots of
people to vote for your site.
So the site was Bletchley Park.
And we kind of had a running
battle with the Needles Old
Battery on the Isle of Wight.
You could see online
who was winning.
And as soon as it looked like
the Needles Old Battery was
kind of moving up in terms
of the amount of votes
that they got, we'd sort
of push out loads of stuff
and get people to vote
and tell everyone else
and get them to vote and kind of
do it in a really-- not a chain
reaction, like a ripple effect.
It's kind of a
way to try and get
more and more people to vote
on stuff or to lobby people
or-- it just grew
into some really
kind of amazing organic
campaign over the years.
And so it was like if
someone saw some opportunity,
they'd alert someone
else and they'd alert--
and it just kind of grew
into this massive thing
where as soon as
there was one message,
someone pinged
something, it just
went out really quickly to
lots and lots of people.
And then we all swooped
in to do whatever
it was that needed to be done.
So I campaigned
over several years.
Here's my family.
So my two sons there,
for their 23rd birthday--
this is during the
campaign-- I said that I'd
take them on a surprise trip.
And you know, looking back,
I just think, how on Earth
did they put up
with me doing all
this stuff over several years?
So for their 23rd birthday,
they got an exciting trip
to Bletchley Park.
And here we are, standing
outside Station X.
And it's just, I
couldn't have done
what I'd done without
my family supporting me.
And they've just been so
ridiculously supportive.
Even my kids, kind of growing
up, like my little one there.
You know, they've
all basically put up
with me spending so
much spare time trying
to raise awareness
of Bletchley Park,
and I really thank
them for that.
So just a couple of other things
that we did during the time.
As I said, I was always trying
to find influential people.
I found a guy called
Phil Willis, MP,
who'd just started
using Twitter,
and he was head of the
Universities and Science
Committee.
I saw him tweeting and
I just thought, oh,
I'm going to see if he's
interested in Bletchley Park.
I think he probably will be.
So I tweeted him, ended up
chatting to him on Twitter,
and then got a 10-minute
slot to go in and chat
to him about Bletchley Park.
So I went in to see him.
And I told him all
about the campaign
and said, what can you do?
What can you do
for Bletchley Park?
And he said, I'll set up an EDM.
So I said, wow, that's great.
What's an EDM?
I had absolutely no
idea what it was.
And it's an Early
Day Motion, which
he said was basically
to raise awareness
in parliament or in government
around different issues.
And so he set up an EDM
asking for operational funding
for Bletchley Park.
So another thing
that happened was
I really wanted to introduce
the people at Bletchley
Park, the management, to the
international museum community
to kind of get them
networked in with all
of these people
around the world.
And I also wanted the
international museum community
to know about Bletchley Park
and what they were doing,
and the fact that
they needed help.
So I wrote a paper
with Kelsey Griffin
from Bletchley Park
and Professor Jonathan
Bowen, who's a museums expert.
And we submitted our paper.
And luckily, it got accepted
for this conference.
And then when it got
accepted, I though,
oh no, what have I done?
Because the conference
is in Denver.
I've now kind of set
Bletchley Park up
to have to pay for
me and someone else
to go over to Denver
and deliver the paper.
But what I'm
actually trying to do
is to get money to come
in to Bletchley Park.
So I was a bit depressed
about what I did,
the sort of situation
that I'd engineered,
not really thinking
about the money aspect.
And so just chatting about that
on Twitter with some friends,
they persuaded me to set up
a JustGiving account, which
I did.
And it amazed me that,
within two weeks,
it was fully funded, which meant
that we could go over to Denver
and deliver our paper,
which was great.
And these are the
avatars of all the people
that funded it, so
thanks very much to them.
My favorite is Mr. Grasshead
at the top in the middle.
And so while we were in
Denver, after we delivered
the paper and the
conference finished,
we got stuck there because
of the Icelandic volcano.
So a crazy thing that
happened was that someone
that was coming over
here to give a talk,
I think at Bletchley
Park, on software testing,
we had a mutual friend.
And they saw that we
were stuck in Denver,
and their plane got
turned around in the air,
so they were halfway
to England and they
got sent back to Denver.
So we ended up meeting up
for breakfast one Sunday
and, you know, chatting about
Bletchley Park and stuff.
And so it's Lisa
Crispin who's the person
that we invited for breakfast.
She was saying, what are
you guys going to do today?
And we'd kind of been stuck
in the conference in Denver
for several days.
So we're like, we want
to get out of Denver
and just go and see
some countryside.
And so basically, she
invited us for a day
at her friend's ranch.
And this is me learning
how to talk to a llama
by blowing up its nose.
So I just think it's
like llama whispering.
So I just thought, just some
really random things happened
to me, but great fun too.
So in 2011, about three years
after we started campaigning,
Simon Greenish,
the director, said
that Bletchley Park was
saved, that he knew, then,
that they were
financially stable
and they wouldn't have to close.
So that was really cool.
How much time have I got?
Four minutes?
Is that right.
Yeah.
So another quick thing,
which involves Google.
So I don't know if you saw a
few years ago that the Turing
papers, or some of
Turing's papers,
were up for auction
at Christie's.
And a great guy called Gareth
Halfacree set up a JustGiving
account to try and
help Bletchley Park
to buy the Turing papers.
And after a couple
of weeks, he'd
raised 20,000 pounds,
which was really great,
but I think the asking
price was 300,000.
So unfortunately, he
wasn't anywhere near that.
And I was at an event at Nesta,
and Megan Smith from Google
was speaking on the platform.
I didn't know her.
And I just was kind
of thinking, you know,
I need to approach people.
Who can I talk to?
And I just thought, Google.
They must have some money.
[LAUGHTER]
It's quite funny
saying that here,
because normally I'm
saying that with people
who aren't at Google.
But I'm glad you all laughed
and didn't throw stuff at me.
[LAUGHTER]
So Google, they must
have some money.
So basically, I went to chat to
Megan, told her about Turing,
about Bletchley Park.
She said, send me an email,
so I sent her an email.
And luckily, a couple of
days later or a day later,
a guy called Simon
Meacham, who you
might know from Google,
who was working here,
got in touch via Twitter.
And basically, I told
him what I told Megan.
And basically what
happened was, they
worked together with Peter
Barron from here, I think,
to raise $100,000 to help
Bletchley Park by the Turing
papers.
So unfortunately,
that wasn't enough.
But some things went
on behind the scenes,
and eventually, Bletchley Park
did get the Turing papers,
so that was great.
So thank you, Google,
for making that happen.
So one of the greatest things
for me in being involved
has been to meet
some of the veterans.
Because they're just
incredible people.
They're kind of everything
you want them to be.
They're really smart, usually
really good sense of humor,
just rapier-like wits.
And so this is Jerry Roberts,
here, meeting the Queen.
So it was a great moment
to see that happen,
because when I
started campaigning,
it was like most traditional
institutions just weren't
interested, or just
weren't that keen,
I think, really to get
involved with Bletchley.
So the way that everyone saw
Bletchley Park kind of now
as a going concern, it was
great that that changed.
And it was great to see the
veterans getting recognition
as well.
That was really cool.
And here's just,
I like this photo.
It's me and Simon
Meacham from Google.
So this is the
first time we met up
after we had this
whole-- it's in the book.
I can't do it justice in
one minute or something.
But we had Megan
and Simon Meacham
and me trying to get the
$100,000 from Google,
and trying to make stuff happen.
We just kind of had this very
exciting time, lots of phone
calls, and it was very cool.
And so this is the
first time that we
got to meet up after
all of that happened,
see the Turing papers
at Bletchley Park.
And this is our photo with
the statue of Alan Turing.
So that's a really quick
run through of several years
campaigning.
I'm delighted to be here, and
happy to answer your questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: It's clear
that Bletchley Park
is a tremendously important part
of our cultural and scientific
heritage.
[INAUDIBLE]
SUE BLACK: Thank you.
MODERATOR: We have
some questions.
One in the front.
AUDIENCE: It's
really admirable what
you've done with this
project, but more
touching on the point, why is
it that it got to that point?
And also, for a country
that prides itself
on its Britishness, and also
the disappointing fact that,
for such a long time,
the royal family actually
distanced themselves from the
public apology to Alan Turing.
Why has the government
also taken such a long time
to react upon that as well?
Is there an answer to that?
SUE BLACK: I can
give you my opinion,
but I don't actually
know the answer.
I mean, in my opinion, I think
because it was all kept secret
for such a long
time, it's just not
really in our public
consciousness.
And so by the time
everyone started
to know what had
actually happened there,
it's like it had kind of been
written out of history, really,
so it's like quite hard to
them to put something back
into history.
And I think it's
just taken time,
because I've just seen a
really big change in people's
attitudes from when, like 2007,
when I started campaigning,
you know, most people were sort
of interested, but not really.
Whereas now, if you talk
about Bletchley Park,
everyone's like,
oh, Bletchley Park.
You know, it's really, really
changed in like, what's that,
eight years now.
And I just think probably
because it was kind of written
out of history, so it's quite
hard to just put it back in.
But like once everyone
hears the stories, you know,
hears lots of different
people speaking
about what happened there,
then that kind of helps
it to grow in people's minds
of what it actually was.
And they hear it from various
different places, not just
one place.
So that's my guess.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We actually went to a team
on site in Bletchley Park
like a week ago,
and it was awesome,
so thank you very much.
SUE BLACK: Awesome.
Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: This is
more about, so we
went to the National
Museum of Computing, which
is also at Bletchley Park.
SUE BLACK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And it seemed
like Bletchley Park
had a lot of money,
a lot of funding,
and was doing really well.
The National Museum of
Computing, while fantastic,
was really struggling.
And when we spoke to
the people about it,
there seemed to be a little bit
of a dispute between the two
groups.
I don't know if you have
anything to add on that,
because it seemed
like both of those
were equally worthy
of preservation,
because the National Museum of
Computing has Colossus in it,
and that should not be lost, and
we should definitely keep that.
But I don't know what
your view is on that.
SUE BLACK: How
long have you got?
I think there's-- I still don't
really know why the dispute
happened.
I don't know.
Dermot probably knows
more about it than I do,
having been involved longer.
But from my point of
view, it seems to me
that they both kind of
want the same thing.
They're both
preserving stuff which
is really, really important.
I have always really wanted
them to work together,
but for various reasons,
that hasn't happened yet.
Dermot's got his
thumb up as well.
Because, I think,
being separate,
there's less opportunities
for the site as a whole.
And I think most people from
the outside see it as one place.
And I think, even
though I know, I still
forget to say and the
Museum of Computing.
Because in my head, still,
it's all the same place, right?
But they kind of get left
out, the Museum of Computing.
I don't know what
to do about it.
If it was up to me-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: Next book, maybe.
SUE BLACK: Yeah.
Maybe, maybe.
Maybe me and Dermot will have
a chat afterwards and see
if we can come up with a plan.
But yeah.
I mean, it pains me that
they're not working together,
and especially now
that there's, like,
a fence up between the two.
The first time I saw that, I
honestly did cry, because I
just thought, that's terrible.
But yeah.
I mean, I don't know how
it all started, really.
I think it's just personalities.
I just don't know the story.
I think, like most things, it's
probably a long and complicated
story over many years.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SUE BLACK: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Great.
I think we have
time for one more.
AUDIENCE: In terms of
crowd fund raising,
2008 was quite a long time ago
in internet years, [INAUDIBLE].
How do you think you might
have approached it differently
if you were starting
from scratch now?
SUE BLACK: That's
a good question.
Yeah, I think it is
quite different now.
One thing that
I've really noticed
is that, when people want
to start campaigns now,
they just start them, and
they work straight away, you
know, which didn't
really happen then.
So I think social
media, and the amount
of people using social media,
and people's knowledge of how
to use social media
has really, really,
massively moved on
from 2007 and 2008.
So I think it would have been a
lot farther-- if I was doing it
now, of course,
Bletchley Park probably
would have shut by now.
But if I was trying to do
the same sort of thing now,
I think it would have been
a lot easier, probably.
AUDIENCE: Because
Kickstarting is recognized.
SUE BLACK: Yeah, yeah.
So everyone understands
crowdfunding.
So many more people on Twitter.
You know, I mean, it's just a
kind of a different landscape
really, completely now.
And I see the recent campaign
against taking the suffragettes
out of A-level politics.
So it was my friend who
noticed that who tweeted me.
I said, you should write
a blog post about it.
She wrote a blog post,
she pinged it out,
sent it to all her friends.
I pinged it out to everybody.
Lots of other people pinged
it out to loads of people,
and then, you know, she's
on the news within days,
and stuff happening,
and people listening.
And politicians
are on Twitter now,
which they weren't,
really, then.
And so you can have an impact
much, much more quickly now
than you could then.
MODERATOR: Fabulous.
Thank you very much, Sue.
Thank you very much, Dermot.
[APPLAUSE]
SUE BLACK: Thank you.